you've been critical at the decision not
to publish the obr reports alongside the
government Liz trouser said this morning
there are no plans to bring that
publication forward from when they are
currently at slated 23rd of November is
that good enough
no I don't think it is because right at
the heart of the problems we're
discussing here is a lack of confidence
that the markets have had in the fiscal
credibility of the government's policies
and the way that you establish that
fiscal credibility is you have firstly
credible fiscal targets and we don't yet
know what those are or when they're
going to bite secondly you have the obr
score all the measures including the
spending measures that you've probably
been talking about earlier in the
program and thirdly you have to have the
obr saying that all of that adds up to
hitting those particular targets now the
question then becomes when is the best
time to come forward with that obr
forecast now it's certainly the case you
can't prematurely Bring It Forward and
tomorrow morning would be too early for
example because it is an iterative
process and it takes time but I know
from my discussions with the obr that
they will be ready by the end of this
month to bring a full forecast forward
as opposed to the current date which is
the 23rd of November and why that's
important Sophie is for two reasons
firstly that the earlier you get that
out there assuming that all the numbers
Stack Up and the markets are comfortable
with it the sooner you can start to calm
those markets and the second reason is
that the monetary policy committee will
meet on the 3rd of November are you well
before the 23rd of November in order to
to take its decision on how high to
raise interest rates if it has a
satisfactory obr report before that
meeting on the 3rd of November I would
imagine and expect that the interest
rate rise will probably not be as high
as it otherwise would be and the reason
for that is that that obr report the
fiscal targets would have reassured the
markets there will be less concern about
the inflationary impacts of the
government's policy and therefore the
MPC will be putting interest rates up by
potentially and I do stress potentially
a little bit less and I say that because
these decisions are very finely balanced
the last NPC meeting for example the
vote was split three ways as to where
the movement and interest rates should
go so for stability reasons and keeping
it rates as low as we can and taking the
pressure off people with mortgages Etc
we need to have that obr forecast before
the end of this month
so just to be crystal clear the decision
to not bring forward the publication of
the obr that in your view is going to
directly hit people's mortgage mortgages
I use the word potentially because to
the extent that the lack of that
forecast means that there's greater
uncertainty in the markets which that
forecast could have calmed down and to
the extent that that in turn leads
members of the monetary policy committee
to conclude that they need to raise
rates a little bit higher than they
would otherwise had to have done then
yes there will be a direct knock-on cost
and that's why it is amongst other
reasons so important that that obr
forecast and the fiscal rules the
government's going to work to are
brought forward by the end of this month
now you've also written to the
chancellor asking him to give evidence
to the sac committee that your chair of
the treasury select committee as soon as
possible in the wake of the budget have
you got a reply yet
uh no my latest letter
um well if in fact we we got in touch
with uh the Chancellor's office a few
weeks ago we were told that he wouldn't
be in a position to appear before the
committee until after uh the uh medium
term fiscal plan is presented on the
23rd of November I wrote to him uh
earlier this week to say that I I needed
to hear from him to see him before then
and I've requested a reply from him no
later than the close of business on
Monday so I have not yet uh received to
my knowledge at least unless it's
sitting in somebody's inbox somewhere I
haven't yet received a response to that
but I would hope to and expect to by the
end of Monday
okay now I'm interested to know your
thoughts about the way forward obviously
one of the main reasons the markets were
quite jittery were because of levels of
borrowing Jake Berry on the program
today saying there will be a review of
spending talking about trimming the fat
from government's expenditure how
comfortable are you with the idea of
cutting money from public services
I think it's going to be very tough
indeed because one of the consequences
of higher than expected inflation
compared to what was expected at the
time that those budgets was said is that
of course departments have already had a
real terms budget cut and if you look at
the big budgets like Health like Social
Security like
education and so on they are going to be
a welfare in particular they're going to
be very difficult really to lean too
hard into I think in order to make those
cuts and we've been there's been much
debate for example about whether there
should be an inflationary operating of
benefits well uh they were last
uprighted yep
what just to jump in what is your view
on the operating of benefits do you
think they should be upgraded in line
with inflation
uh I I think we need to have a debate
about all these kind of measures in the
round at the time that we have all the
detail and of course we don't yet uh
have all the detail but I do think there
are some very difficult political Optics
um at the very least around having the
45p rate abolished and then seeking
reductions for example in the welfare
bill now if you were to uprate uh
welfare payments by earnings rather than
inflation you would save about five or
six billion pounds you've got to put
that in the context of an additional 72
billion pounds that's taking place as a
consequence of 45 billion pounds worth
of unfunded tax cuts that gives you a
sense of how far you've got to push in a
politically difficult Direction in order
to try and square the books here through
leaning into expenditure
I think it also gives us a sense of your
own views on it potentially as well Liz
trouser said this morning that she
didn't consult the cabinet on the
scrapping of the 45p rate of tax that
was a decision for the chancellor uh
quasi quateng Shu said do you think she
should have sought a bit more advice
I think she thought she has also said I
think that she feels that perhaps that
the ground should have been laid better
for the fiscal event last Friday and I
think I would put that in that category
in other words it appears to me that
this has been done certainly you know a
lot of stuff done at huge pays quite a
radical approach to institutions and
individuals and processes and the Norms
uh and amongst those various things yes
I think something like a move like that
you want to take your cabinet with you
you would want to discuss it with them
and I think that's typically how that
would have happened in the past
um Jake Bearer is also very clear that
as far as he's concerned if any
conservative MP votes against the budget
or the measures announced in the budget
that will be seen as a confidence Vape
so effectively they would have the whip
removed
do you think that's the right decision
that's uh always typically been the case
that if you vote against a major fiscal
measure in a finance bill then that is
considered a vote of uh confidence
against the government and the
consequence of that would be to have the
whip removed so I think if that is the
position that is adopted then I don't
think it'd be reasonable to say that
that's that's out of sync with uh with
what has happened in the past I think
the question really will be around the
Practical politics of that because
clearly if there are a number of back
benches or a Groundswell of resistance
to a particular measure
um then that would be problematic it is
a question of whether you can hold the
dam or not if you like uh on that and of
course sometimes these these pushes on
particular points can be resolved before
you even reach that point because the
government will on occasion amend the
proposals that it's putting forward none
of that of course on the 45p will come
in for some time because that will be in
a finance bill probably in the early
part of next year
at the same time though it's been pretty
clear from what uh Liz trust and quasi
quantity have said since the budget that
they have no intention of reversing the
45p measure given that how many of your
colleagues do you think might end up
voting against it
oh well I'm not going to get into
speculating around potential future
rebellions sometime uh next year as as I
said earlier I think the important thing
I'm sure that most iconies will be doing
this will be we want to know the full
extent of this package we want to know
where these spending uh cuts that the
government's now talking about are going
to fall and what they will mean and
indeed you know how they will impact
lower income families who who are as
always at times of of economic toil
generally the group that that suffer the
most so
um I think I and all my colleagues will
want to take a level-headed calm and
reasonable look at the entire package
that's on offer here
it doesn't sound like you are entirely
sure how you will be voting on some of
these measures I take the point that you
want to look at it in the round
but is that still
an open question
well I I don't know tremendously repeat
myself Sophie but this this is a very
big fiscal intervention it has many
moving Parts with huge consequences for
the economy and indeed for individuals
and families and businesses up and down
the country there's a lot happening and
I think it's only right particularly
when we get this obr forecast as I say
the earlier the better that we really
have a chance to look at that and look
at the detail and see how it all fits
together what the distributional impacts
are for example of all the measures that
are being undertaken and and quite
rightly the government is saying that
you know the the intervention on
supporting uh households or the with
their fuel bills will be
disproportionately beneficial to those
lower income households because they
have a higher proportion of their
expenditure uh that that's accounted for
by energy costs so there are swings and
roundabouts here and you have to look at
it in the round
uh briefly because I I'm out of time but
I want to squeeze one more in
um will Liz trust lead the conservative
party into the next election
sorry I slightly missed that when
so will Liz trance lead them I will
we'll trust yeah will she I I I
certainly hope so because
um for that to happen I think it's fair
to say that we have to fairly quickly
move to a place where the polls are
beginning to turn around where the
markets are feeling that the government
is behaving fiscally responsible and
they're gaining in confidence and the
pressure on the pound is being uh
released somewhat and bond yields are
not soaring off uh as as we see and if
that doesn't happen so then I Then I
then I think we are in hugely difficult
uh Waters